this is a production of cornell
university
uh thanks everyone joining the uh this
is gonna be episode 15 of the cornell
turf show this spring
uh we're excited to have a practitioner
on today sean pister director of grounds
at longwood garden
sean you've been a live viewer for all
our spring uh spring episodes this
uh this year so we're happy to have you
on today to talk about
your practical knowledge frank we're
getting a little bit out of the ivory
tower here we're going to talk to some
boots on the ground so we're excited to
hear
uh some of the really cool kind of
sustainability initiatives data
collection initiatives that sean's got
going
at longwood so we'll uh we'll transition
into that conversation a little bit
later
uh but as always frank um you know we're
kind of always got these weather swings
i know
you'll update us a little bit on the
weather uh what do you got for us this
morning
well i got what happens when you try to
get too close to the air conditioner
right sean
not not not a good not a good move here
uh
welcome everyone thanks carl and thanks
sean for for
joining us you know this is the time of
year where
uh where everybody's out mowing
particularly in our neck of the woods
right this is
time when things start growing at a
really rapid rate
so let's just look at the weather for a
second and it starts out with um
uh you know understanding how the season
has progressed and if you don't
visit this website regularly i commend
it to you as an easy look
to see you know are we ahead are we
behind
are we sort of at normal of what i might
expect
now you got to remember normal's changed
quite a bit in the last 20 30 years with
the changing climate of course
but this is a good indication as you can
see that you know most of us in the
northeast are well ahead of normal
although as you get down to philly and
where
sean is down there uh you know they're
like in a
sort of in-between pattern where it was
warm and
and now it's sort of holding on and a
lot of people are talking about
how the blooms have been so persistent
the the last several weeks due to some
of the cooler weather well
from a lawn perspective if you're out in
the professional lawn care industry
certainly you're out
thinking about crabgrass at this time of
year right the forsythia bloom is
probably
half green half gold by now most
probably have their pre-emergent
materials on it towards the southern
part of the region
but you can see that the crab grass is
still early germination
for those of us further north uh as you
see along the lakes
the germination prediction is a little
bit more advanced and those
areas of the state around rochester
and buffalo are the most advanced in the
entire northeast region
as far as relative to normal so it's
been unusually warm
in the balmy buffalo in rochester not
something you associate typically with
things being cooler
but obviously the other thing we're
seeing a lot of and this is a picture
from uh
uh somebody in ontario that was uh you
know lambasting the community for
banning herbicides and saying you know
this is the
rite of spring up here in ontario so you
know many years ago
the herbicides were banned uh synthetic
materials were banned from the consumer
market
one of the few places in north america
where that happens and is
regularly enforced the municipalities as
well
uh do not use and haven't for almost a
decade now
uh any herbicides so they rely a lot on
corn gluten meal
uh and fiesta now here here in our
country
we use uh 240 and other broadleaf
herbicides
and there are two formulations that you
can typically buy these products in
either the ester or the amine
and it's worth noting here as the
favorable time
for both esther and amin begin to
progress
if you're going to make a spring
application which is not always my
favorite recommendation because
it's unlikely to give you a complete
kill the best chance you got is by
following these models that
have been developed around uh timing in
the spring
a movement of photosynthetic material
from the leaves to the roots
that has some chance of getting some
long-term kill here so
this is really the only guiding
principle we can give you on good
uh broadleaf herbicide use in the spring
is try to use these models that are
available at our forecast website to do
this now
nothing's going to stop people from
going out and doing the five in one
right
we figured out a way to stuff everything
into granules and bags and
i think herbicides are at q4 or q5
now where you get grass and sedge and
broad leaf and pre-emergent
control all in one so you know these are
the kinds of things that
i understand them from a convenience
perspective but it's virtually
impossible to get all the timing of
control of these things
done at the same time nevertheless labor
and
time that people have is what you know
the lack of those things is what's make
these products
uh convenient and widely used but none
of us in the professional ranks
would necessarily defer to something
like this i would hope
because we have some flexibility and
knowledge to know
when is the right time to do things so
as we move forward and we start talking
about growth and get into our discussion
with sean we start out with one of the
things that
gets and keeps things going and that's
the moisture
and while we like the hanging around
rich buckley that wherever he goes it's
going to rain
he is likely to be in a drier part of
the region now what's not known
number one is it's been fairly dry as
you get into the center part of
pennsylvania
and into uh the huds into orange county
and
new york and down in the allegheny
plateau you see some really dry spots
there
as evapotranspiration levels start to
build now you notice in the other map
that's projecting out into may the
second week of may
there's a line between normal and above
normal precipitation that looks like
it's at the bottom of pennsylvania and
excluding south jersey now that's the
line that's going to move and as that
line moves
over the next couple of weeks we're
going to have more or less rain
wet to the north drier to the south uh
it's going to be cooler to the north and
warmer to the south so
in general we're going to see some very
interesting shifts in growth number one
temperatures are going to be much warmer
in the evening time which is going to
keep the average above normal
and that's going to keep the cool season
grasses well on their way to active
growth now
we had bill on the show bill criser on
the show a number of years ago a number
of years ago oh yeah yeah
it felt like a number of years ago carl
it was only a few weeks ago that we had
bill here
talking about the difference between
growth potential that you predict
based on this model here and what you
actually measure when you collect
clippings so you see the blue line here
on unirrigated kentucky bluegrass
there's a lot of good growth happening
on this bluegrass in the early part of
the year
drops off in the summer months and then
picks up again later in the season so
there's a little bit of a bimodal
pattern and a very dry period there now
if you're growing tall fescue
it appears to be a little bit different
right where you do not see as much
aggressive spring growth and this grass
as the climate's changing
is going to be more uh aggressively
growing during the summer months and
then drop
off in the fall so this is irrigated
tall fescue
that doesn't appear to be following that
bimodal curve so it's really important
to understand
the grasses that you're growing because
eventually
with the rainfall coming we're going to
have situations like this
where we've got to deal with clippings
now for those of you in working in the
urban landscape
now sean you're a little bit removed off
there in longwood you've got some
pavement that you've got to deal with
but this is a rite of spring really
throughout the northeast
unfortunately you know we're spilling
fertilizers we're blowing clippings
uh you know we don't want to use blowers
so we got people out there trying to
brush
the pavement with the clippings and you
know we turn
a lawn that should be a green filter
right where it's filtering these things
into a gray funnel right we're putting
all these clippings into this gray
funnel that allows the
things to get into the waterways and
i've been a sort of really beaten on
this the last several weeks
and just reminding everybody about our
urban fertilization
guidelines that was developed a number
of years ago by our scientists up here
in the northeast
and in there you'll see for
non-sensitive areas
and for sensitive areas the way we
recommend
very little nutrients in both of these
cases
you see if you're making only one
fertilizer application or two fertilizer
applications
right you're just in that time where you
might will make one now
most of it has slow release nitrogen
more than 50
as slow release nitrogen so i really
want to avoid
a good slug of nitrogen now because i
don't want
this right which is likely to happen uh
as we progress
now listen sean you know as we
transition to you here
um you know i i uh
i know you've done a lot with watering
uh but because
this time and we're gonna have you back
on don't worry to talk about the
watering and the uh the cool stuff that
you do with that
and i know you were an early adopter of
the in-ground sensors and the ugg mode
technology
so i certainly want to have you back to
talk about that but today
i want to talk about the way you mow
these things because
this has been a consistent point of
discussion
among people now certainly in a formal
garden like this
you see the striping i remember when you
built this beautiful little
amphitheater there this is just such a
beautiful thing for those
folks that uh have never visited this
spectacular piece of land
you gotta get yourself down there to see
the great work that shawn's doing i
don't have any of the patterns there
sean
but i do have you know some of the data
that you collect
uh like when you start mowing and you
can see
um you know it's it's very variable
there it looked like you were mowing
earlier
it's something that varies a lot over
time but it is a piece of data
it looks like you're not uh mowing in
some areas there
uh for reasons and of course you know
dan talked about this at cornell
uh a number of weeks ago uh where we've
been doing it and promoting it for using
less gas
i picked up this picture because i
thought it was cool of you guys mowing
with the flymo
uh this is a lecture i guess you gave at
longwood
uh not long ago and here are the
questions for today pal
um you know as as you look at the 22
years
managing what 170 some odd acres there
at longwood
i'm sort of interested in how things
have evolved over that time
and and where you've made adjustments
both i know
i want to hear a little bit about mowing
certainly i know we'll hear about
watering
and then you know as you've collected
data how's that helped
and then you know a lot of people
listening or
tuning in you know are wondering well
that's really good isn't longwood
you know i'd like to i don't know where
to start right where's it where's a good
entry point so
let me uh stop sharing and take a look
at you
and start with that first question you
know 22 years at a place like that
um and i know i gosh i i guess we've
known each other at least 15 of those
years
interacting since you had me down there
um tell me what it's like how it's
changed over the years
well thank you for having me on i told
carl this is like my ted talk so this is
the rock stars of turf
so i appreciate it um but so it's an
evolution right it's i i came here 22
years ago
i remember this the day i drove up from
my interview coming off a route one
coming through
the main entrance and thinking this is
very naive of me then
how easy was going to be because all's i
saw was yellow meaning we had dandelions
everywhere
and it was an evolution because at that
time in place
longwood wanted to everyday do
everything they could
sustainability-wise from a turf
standpoint
and that meant we we were not allowed to
put broadleaf weed control down
so it had to do with picking the right
species making sure we get the soil in
shape
so over time by tracking information and
having that data point
i then was allowed to have more tools
given to me for my toolbox
so that didn't mean that hey shawn go
out and buy your
your boom sprayer and start spraying
it's like no what areas
is going to be affected by the display
what areas does the public so
i think you can see the image behind me
so this is one of the mowing patterns
it's really a brush pattern right we
can't mow this we do this
like you do on a baseball field we do
with brooms and water pressure
but we started asking what what is what
can turf add to the display at longwood
and more importantly what can we do not
to take away
the display of our landscape managed
areas right
we call it the frame it's the frame of
the the
the the for the aesthetics that we have
so don't
detract from that so so so when you got
there and it was all yellow you didn't
use any herbicides it was a matter of
systematically
fixing the soil putting the right
species in
irrigating them properly and so for
how many years have you not used
synthetic herbicides out there
so we were not allowed to use any
herbicides let's see if i
in 2000 probably in 2004 so maybe the
first five years here we were not
allowed to use any herbicides
on the turf grass and then we slowly
opened it up and we said okay
this is a high priority area and so we
have maps of all the gardens and we said
okay how about this area if we do one
application in the fall to reduce the
pressure
and then the other tool i use is i said
you know what message are we sending to
the guests at longwood about managing
turf grass if we have
i mean truly some of the areas were 100
weeds and so i use it i said well turf
is a great filter
i said so we're allowing more runoff we
have bare ground in the winter time i
said this is the wrong message
and so it slowly got handed over and so
then we could do
a little bit of broadleaf weeds then we
could open up and do some aeration and
overseeding
but when i first came here longwood has
really good topsoil
but it was extremely extremely high in
magnesium and so the soils were very
tight
and so we put a lot of high cal lime
down in gypsum
to get our soils in shape and now part
of it is is from
your training of me frank is we're now
on a five-year rotation for soil testing
we have the soils in such good shape now
we don't need to do them every year now
the one behind me that's sand based so
we do
test that once a year but it was just an
evolution it was getting
my bosses comfortable with me how was i
going to manage things and it all
started with those data points
and once you have data points then you
can say hey you know we start mowing
typically
now we need to have this many staff
members and so we slowly grew
we had five full-time turf grass
technicians we're up to seven full-time
turf grass technicians
that we have and so it's it's that
evolution of learning things
uh learning what longwood is about
learning the message we want to give to
the guests
because i'll be honest with you there
are guests that see behind me and they
think i'm a nozzle head and we do not do
that
and so that's part of our education too
that we do not the turf behind me is not
sprayed on a weekly basis
it does not have broadleaf we control
used all the time um
you can do that if you get your soils in
shape and you do the right strategies
um with things and so that's part of our
part of our mission
so little by little you've had to adapt
to
allow certain things to uh you know
remove
some shade issues improve traffic flow
and i would imagine that was a big deal
uh during covet that traffic
created a stress maybe you hadn't seen
uh
in the same way i i don't know how you
guys restricted during that time
but one of the things that it does make
me wonder about is
it is like an afterthought i mean most
people
are not thinking about well yeah sean
okay the grass would you please cut it
if you cut it it looks good i mean we
get this a lot
mowing solves a lot of weed problems
because nobody noticed them if they're
not flowering until you bring it to
their attention
oh we have bare ground oh we have this
so
how i guess again we got a lot of people
listening and might be saying yeah i
can't even get them to pay attention to
me i can't even get them to realize
what's happening
what were some of the earliest steps you
took to say hey
you know we got to fix this and here
before you even embarked upon a plan
i feel like so many people can't get
their own administrators attention for
these things
or their own bosses in a lawn care
operation attention for these things
what advice would you give those folks
well first it starts with
you got to be professional right that's
the first thing so i'm a
i'm a stickler on terms and i'll get my
i'll i'll pick on my crew sometimes when
they use it it's not
just turf right and we're not mowing
guys
so they are turf grass technicians they
all have four-year turf degrees
and i said we're here to elevate that i
said just like we have
uh horticulturists here that have a lot
of years experience the same thing from
turf i said so you have to look at it
through that lens
and communicate it through that lens
that you're not just out there mowing
so like i'll have the hort team
sometimes they're like you guys just
smell
and i go no that's not what we do uh for
things or they'll say
well you can go get sod right saad is
like carpet you buy it by the yard so if
something goes wrong
just go resot it and i go no that's not
our sustainability initiative that's not
what we're trying to do
we have that tool in our toolbox but
that shouldn't be our first gut feeling
we need to protect the turf or we're
going to set a stage up we have to
educate performing arts about this so
it's
it's using those right terms i think
frank to make sure that people realize
you're elevating it up to what it should
be
it shouldn't be the mo and blow guys
that's not who we have here at longwood
that's not the last question well it's
clear that what you've been able to do
is communicate it and it's clear that
you've got a staff that
can do it but you've also had to make
adjustments
in equipment in the you know the the
the way you do line trimming the
under pressure for energy use and then
you know to lead into my next question
have you raised the mowing height to mo
less have you
found areas where you mow them less
frequently
and what does it take to manage that
less frequently mode
area versus a regularly mode manicured
turf like behind you because
i think a lot of people look at them
showing and they say oh yeah well
they're not doing anything over there
right
they stopped mowing they're not doing
anything as if it's no management
and i wonder if you couldn't talk to us
a little bit about what that looks like
to
manage a area you don't mow as much
intentionally
sure sure so that's great question so um
those who don't know so
so frank was part of our peer review
group back in 2012
and one of one of the items that came
out to us was why are you mowing
everything weekly
right great question so we took that to
heart and we stopped mowing certain
areas
weekly and frank i thought i
communicated i had maps i had everything
down
after six months they're like what are
you doing that's right they're gonna
remember
you up we weren't gonna mow these areas
and um
so we took it too far so we we had to
peel it back and so areas that i thought
were no-brainers of
these aren't going to be impacted by the
gas or the guests is gonna
aesthetically they didn't work so we
peeled that back so probably about half
of those areas that we took out and
there was probably about three acres
worth of turf
where we said we'll just smoke monthly
right we'll take it down
what we learned too early on is if you
stop mowing
you're going to have weeds that come in
so you make sure you stay on top of it
so we do make sure we go through with a
pre-emergent and we do do a broadleaf
weed control now
as needed for those areas but there are
areas now that are there we're probably
down about one and a half acres that we
only mow once a month now
that we've gotten to that aesthetic and
the other one we use it as a tool so one
of them
is in our grass overflow parking lot
what better way to keep
security and other people from putting a
car in an area than having the top
the tall grass and so instead of putting
a fence up that they could take down or
a string line
we now have it up so they know they if
they can't go in it right because
nobody's going to park a car in it
so we use that as another tool uh in our
toolbox for this but you're absolutely
right it was a learning curve
we thought we were doing the right thing
i thought i was doing the right thing
but it just didn't fit with our
aesthetics and so
being a public garden um you always have
to keep that in the back of your mind
that it's that balancing act between
what are you doing
input wise for turf grass to the
aesthetic part that the guest is
is is not going to be discouraged by but
we we also did a trial in the gardens uh
with penn state university about
using different fine fescues hard
fescues things like that
it was one of the best trials we ever
did it was front and center we had
information
on it i don't know how much play time i
got off of that by guess
asking me as well as other people
outside of longwood asking me
what did you learn how did you do things
and there's a local golf course down the
road that learned from it and they did
hard fescue along their road edges and
they don't moan now
and they're like we learned this by
senior trial um so it was just a great
offshoot that we did but
it all started with i'm very curious by
nature i want to know
i want data to back it up right i don't
want to do a knee-jerk reaction and do a
well-thought-out plan for things the
other
misnomer too being along with is people
think we have unlimited resources
granted we have very good resources we
do not have unlimited resources right so
we have to be smart about it
um for things now going back to covid
we unfortunately i don't know how it was
in new york so we were put in the bucket
of casinos and uh movie theaters so we
were closed for two and a half months
so we were an outdoor venue that was
told we had to close
until we could get to the green phase so
pa did
red yellow green we couldn't even open
in yellow
so it was the most disheartening thing
to know that we have a thousand seventy
seven acres
350 with which is open outdoors we
cannot let a guest inside
um it was heartbreaking we're working on
that now because it's part of an
education we need to educate
our government about what longwood is
about but
from a knee-jerk reaction they put us in
the wrong bucket and we had to stay
closed and it was heartbreaking to see
in the spring
one of our best spring displays ever our
thousand
tulips that came up our geophyte display
nobody could see them
and so we had we had to go through that
but once again it was a learning lesson
for for all of us yeah
well listen one of the things that
forced a lot of people to realize and
you know
there's two things i want to go back
with you about one is
to the mowing thing and the weed control
issue because
it's real and what you describe is
exactly a lot of times what golf courses
have to do with these naturalized areas
on the property
where they have weeds that come and
they've got to use pre or post emergent
products
to keep the weeds out so i'm you know
that pretty much i i think
over time you'd like to think you don't
have to spray a pre-year or sedge
doesn't become a problem
you can't get away with it can you no no
no not true not true
we have not we have not hit that sweet
spot where we can skip that
okay all right so that's the first thing
that the the first thing there the the
the uh this uh what was the second thing
we were talking about the fine fescues
along the roads growing
the use of data over time that was the
transition i wanted to make thank you
very much for bringing up data
you say you had data points you must
have people above you
who you who understand data
[Music]
understood it for a while you've you
know saying like you've been at it for
the last 15
20 years um how do you start that
is it simple numbers and you know simple
things like the first time we start
mowing that's something good
we should know that and track that how
do you decide
what date is good to take and what can
be made
well a lot of it comes back to frank our
budgets and so by having like our start
mowing date i can say
if we're going to contract out an area i
know historically it's going to take
26 cuts a year right or if the if the
growing season is longer
and say hey to our accountant this is
why it cost me two extra cuts right
the growing season the temperature was
this so by having that data you have to
justify everything that we do now
um just about all of our species of turf
here we do turf type tall fescue
uh we look at the end tip trials we look
at the best ones and our mowing height
to your point is we mow it three to
three and a half inches so we mow
taller right we could probably go down
to two and a half inches but i say why
like why are we doing that going back to
we want the
the guests to leave and say well if
longwood's doing it right i can do this
at my home lawn i don't need to be
um doing that right we're constantly
learning we're constantly giving out
that education to them
um so we can hopefully change that
perception and change the image like
quite quite frankly
something's got to change i mean you
bought it up the five in one i love
going to home depot and seeing stuff
like that
oh please well listen this is what the
grassroots exhibit at the national
arboretum was going to try to do a while
ago
i'm so glad to see you committed to that
and carl how about some questions are
there any questions or comments you have
uh for sean yeah so i think one of the
things you mentioned frank is is for
some of the people listening who have
very few resources and are trying to
communicate to their bosses
sean i hear you are talking a lot about
how you had to kind of scale up your
resources when you started at longwood
kind of identifying so you're starting
with these data points and then you're
kind of scaling up based on priorities
you talked about
varieties you talked about soils how
important is it
when you first go to your boss and start
talking about hey i need some more
resources
how important is it to prioritize and
try and scale create a plan to scale
up uh when you go into that first sort
of conversation with um
you know with the people above no
absolutely i mean you have to have your
vision right so you say this is where
we're at
this is where i want to get these are
the steps that it's going to take
incrementally to get there and so the
first step for me was
hey we're mowing everything the right
way we have the right species in here
the soil is where it needs to be how
about we have this next tool
and we start prioritizing where that
tool is going to be used right
so it's not you're asking for a
significant amount of dollars it's a
little bit
right and then we got some savings the
one item i didn't mention is is
we used to use all organic fertilizer
here and we went away from that
and so now we only put down fertilizer
in the fall we use a slow release
product called duration
and that cut our fertility in half so i
had a huge
labor savings from that as well as a
product savings
that i could then roll and say hey you
know i'm doing this sustainable item
how about i use those dollars for this
other tool that i need
and it's it's all about that and luckily
at longwood we're all on the same page
in terms of our vision we want to
elevate we want to do things but we want
to keep it in a sustainable
way and once you do that you can do it
um the stuff behind me right that didn't
happen overnight that wasn't year five
that wasn't year ten
that was that was much much longer that
was me pushing
pushing the pushing my folks to keep
them engaged and to keep them
wanting to do more i'm like you know can
we do this right and the the the pattern
behind me is one of our senior turf
guest technicians
he took it to heart and he's been doing
this for five years now and he comes up
with all this himself
and i just stick hand back stand back
and go wow that's amazing
it's amazing what we did i'm wondering
sean when you didn't get the visitors
and it was just you guys doing the work
did you notice bad habits about the way
you guys moved around the garden
are there some places you drive mowers
like on golf courses everybody drives
you know a lot of people were shut down
and they could you know there was no
golfers to complain about it's like oh
look barry is still dead maybe it's us
did you get a look at some of the things
that you do
through a lens that you hadn't seen
before and make some adjustments based
on that
so when so when it first shut us down
which was march 13th
not only did it shut the guests down
from a staffing standpoint we
prioritized so we were just gearing up
to start mowing
and we were told no no no nobody that
was not essential so i could come to
work
my team couldn't come to work for the
first week so i'm sitting here sweating
bullets going if we don't get them here
we're gonna have a hay field
and then i had to tell them the
unfortunate news which i repeated to him
i said i will never you will never hear
me use these words again
i said but due to the pantemic just mow
the grass
i said you just need to keep it
maintained i said don't worry about
string trimming don't worry about edging
i said
because we didn't know what our staffing
level was going to be given it
i mean if you recall back i mean we've
truly thought the sky was falling we
didn't know what was
what was so we told everybody stay away
come here the guys literally came in for
two or three days a week
and they just cut it's like just cut it
just cut it just cut it
and that was the same point too where
the conservatories that we have
we had to start making hard decisions
because we were gearing up for the next
display right what do we do we have a
greenhouse full of crops well the next
one is coming in what do we do
and so we had a lot of heart-wrenching
decisions to make about uh the compost
stream and where these plants were going
and um but we all got through it and so
we're just going back to communication
but
did you notice any any any negative
effects from
uh having to let it grow or did it get
out of hand to the point where you
violated the
one-third rule and and did the grass uh
get weakened a little bit
so we violate the one-third rule so it
was interesting because you know we have
five million geophytes in turf grass
locations so if you want to have an area
not to mow
which is not i'm not suggesting this um
you're going to violate the one-third
rule and so the grass will turn brown
it will look unsightly it will be weedy
for a while and we're learning through
that as well
but absolutely frank there were areas
that as you're not as bad as the image
you showed but we definitely were making
some hay
in some areas but we caught up i mean we
just did what we normally do we caught
up
and the turf responded and we're back to
pretty much
normal from from that standpoint at
least for this year well we're getting
close to wrapping up sean and
i just want to ask you one more thing
because it is a
you know pressing issue and you are
seeming to take a lead in communicating
things
how are you talking to the people who
you've been around for 20 something
years about how the climate's changing
and how it's impacting what you're doing
and i'm assuming you're noticing it
i thought your start date thing was a
little bit interesting but
tell me how you're even having that
conversation with people in the garden
so absolutely so i'm also responsible
for the arbors team
and so the the nursery woody plant
production team so we've started that
frank from the tree side where we know
now
we have climate change models that um
the forestry service worked with us on
and so we have a hundred year model
that'll tell you which species are going
to be
declining in habitat increasing and so
we go to put a tree back we now use that
model to do it
and we also have a specimen replacement
plan to preserve our historic trees
so we unfortunately right when that
pandemic started a 180 year
historical cucumber magnolia national
champion cute national
champion cucumber magnolia uprooted
we luckily 15 years ago had a cutting
from that tree and so we've replanted
that tree in kind
to preserve it we call it keeping our
hand on our
founder's shoulder and so preserving the
past to move forward and so we have a
genetic replica now
that'll be tethered to that historic
tree knowing that we've kept the
genetics alive so we're all over it now
i am so glad i asked that question carl
aren't you glad i asked that
question sean what a joy having you pal
it's so great to see you and thanks so
much for taking the time to chat with us
uh i'll look forward to doing this again
when we're talking watering because that
stuff that you're doing is really worth
uh everybody hearing about thanks a lot
sean carl it's all yours brother
yep as always sean uh that that was
awesome it's great to hear what you guys
are doing at longwood so for our
listeners viewers
you know longwood gardens down there in
pennsylvania you know to go check it out
if you're not watching that the visuals
behind sean that he's got of those
aesthetics of the turf areas are are
pretty cool so
i appreciate you coming on sean uh we'll
see everybody next week
uh thursday golf show we'll have jim
brosnan on from tennessee we'll be
talking some weed stuff
always exciting but until then uh take
it easy everybody
see you guys next week sean thanks so
much this has been a production of
cornell university
on the web at cornell.edu